maybe is here's our man it's a nemesis
like what's his name
it's dynamicists I also just why is so
low Jesus Christ is gonna that's gonna
terrify me so much Thank You Ross well
that was a very delayed delayed ping for
your super chat but hey ho got a
jump-scare before the game even started
she's a little bit ill now she's on
caution that's okay hello oh wait what
this is not like a doll that I can go
through what do you mean remember we
have to use something on the computers
here you go
December Cesare sporadic test run at
University - I brought it back to campus
64% infection and conversation a
conversation conversion no survivors got
eyes on two stars a male infected he was
infected did we know that do we know
that already I can't remember and a
female bioweapon is pursuing the female
well I [ __ ] know that don't I buy
weapon deployed cases when he came on
there there's a video attached of a
knight skirmish in confined area with a
large number of combatants female JV has
made contact with MV / - yes I did
bioweapons appearance and behavior are
consistent with project and
investigating observed by weapon
wielding Kampf conventional weapons it
seems to be strongly fixated on
terminating JV Jill Valentine and knows
the city layout evidence it can be
imprinted metamorphosis in the bio
weapon triggered by a hoss
counter wait so someone's been like
watching us this whole time
wait was it him the dude what's his name
evil guy that killed his other platoon
member was it him he's been following us
over 17 hours have elapsed since Jill
valentine's exposure conversion has been
slow she's suggesting she may be
resistant so they even know about me
getting the vaccine and everything
recovered and administered by a soldier
in the tune she expected to be fit for
come back to what 20 20 hours per
exposure it seems clear the bio work
weapon his project and or maybe it's
like call his name's Carlos right yeah
maybe as Carlos his friend do you think
he's the spy that would be a twist but
it's probably not it's probably that
evil dude that we saw up here because I
mean he was up here so it makes sense
are you a spy I got through there really
to negotiate don't trust him he'll call
off the strike gift and this is one big
ass if we can deliver the vaccine event
before they launch how long do we have
hours maybe then let's not waste one
more second this way
because how the hell did you guys say
he's got Nicholai Nicholai
how does he know everything without
being there and this is a very sneaky
come on Jill
sure you don't need to stop stop and do
what I got you back all right let's get
this done I'm the one who can't run here
running caution why can't I run
maybe he maybe he wasn't the spy
[Music]
okay nemesis has turned into something
else he is like evolved in ways I could
never imagine Jesus I need to turn down
this game because it's so loud oh thank
you thank you for the shower appreciate
it we don't have anything
who's this employee regulations the
objectives of this t-virus research
facility different from those of
umbrella this main NASA facility here we
focus on real-world use cases which
arise as new bioweapons are created and
introduced such as the need for t-virus
vaccines and new weaponry capable of
suppressing bioweapons some aspects of
our work here can be dangerous so it's
an it is imperative that all employees
adhere to workplace regulations start
fail in particular unauthorized entry by
unapproved visitors or the removal of
the removal of work-related data or
materials will be met with severe
disciplinary measures it is great honor
to be part of the finest research
organization in the world keep this in
mind and stick to the rules as we forge
new and revolutionary technologies ah
sweet we don't map oh there's some
healthier green hab
oh boy I passed it shall I wait till I
can hopefully find a red herb yeah put
one of these in here
Magnum
well this is quite creepy
do you think sue that this look is a
dead end
I [ __ ] knew it I knew it
Oh white oh my god
why why are you so invincible by it that
you please I'll get back up please get
back up look bad shot [ __ ] up
ketchup don't get back up don't get back
up I miss the crate Oh shotgun shells oh
yeah and a diary the pay was generous
the benefits were good most importantly
they promised me I'd be contributing to
the state-of-the-art medical tech
research for university teachers start
working in nowhere America it was a
golden opportunity like winning the
lottery so I went for it I made the
pitch to my family and we agreed to move
here to Raccoon City well in hindsight
hindsight is 20/20 because this lab is a
den of monsters who could duck cruel and
barbaric experiments with sole purpose
of taking human life in the most
sickening way possible it's messed up
the world Lisa no but every time I work
up the courage to blow the whistle I
think of penny and KC and immediately
chickened out
I guess that's his family umbrella owns
this town there was this guy they caught
trying to smuggle out company secrets
they essentially fed him to one of the
betas fed him I saw the whole thing I
got my wife we've got her into this I
just need to do my job do as I'm told
for their sake but let this be a
testament to all that I do have a
conscience and I've learned my lesson
well I just shot you in the head sorry
sir but I'm glad you have a conscience
at least that's nice too
Oh [ __ ] up they just got back up again
hopefully they won't follow me in this
room hello
I don't trust any hello I don't trust
anything on the floor to not get back up
to most efficiently synthesize a vaccine
both an antigen and an ant juvett
what adjuvant adjuvant are required the
antigen that produces an immune response
while the adjuvant increases the effects
of such responses leading to increase
antibody production by combining samples
of these two ingredients one can create
a potent vaccine base by processing this
vaccine base with our propriety
equipment a larger batch of vaccine can
be created with astonishing ease what's
more my latest antigen and antibody
simples yield unprecedented rates of
antibody production for using more than
1000 times the yield of Tron the
traditional materials this not only
makes it an effective vaccine but also a
potential way to eliminate existing
infections where is it hey can I use
this
over 90 successfully generated what have
we here overwrite what can we use this
full then in here what's this okay
awesome
let's pick up yes
hello oh bloody footprints what's yours
I think he said he's not getting up so
he's probably dead
okay so let's go back and see what we
can use this one I think that one got up
to me
still scat me I knew you were up and
he's still scared
we sing
aha so I'm guessing here yes
not wasting market bullets on you no no
this one I'm fine maybe I will Oh God
whoa what the [ __ ] is that oh my god
that's so creepy I can it's no fun
oh my god I don't want to go in there
that is really creepy
oh my god
ah there's more are you you have to take
your disgusting
oh my god please sign how are you not
dead
oh my guys coming upstairs oh that's so
freakin creepy oh well now it's supposed
to do it over the barriers not freaking
on them it's so stupid
I would like to formally request that
the weaponry normally reserved the bio
weapons synthesis team be made available
for any employees it's faced with the
admission and dismissal of test subjects
these senseless jerks do not sent them
the same level as the danger as a by one
product by bleed this weaponry
authorization is advisable Baba recently
some test subjects have developed a new
mutation granting them very high
regrowth abilities oh these are the
things outside pale heads they have been
appearing with regularity but the
specific cause has not yet been
determined
uh-oh this is why they take so long to
kill because they regenerate correctly
any source of system failure were to
occur within our facility we would be
woefully under threat of protect
ourselves I'd like to request the
high-powered weaponry capable of
subduing the pale hair to be issued to
all our employees wait am I gonna get a
new gun
thank you oh did you see that somebody
just move it's like I hate that my very
much
get back down oh oh
[ __ ] die cuz I can hear the pale head
coming behind me and I think they're
worse than you we old [ __ ] right too
much happening too much happening okay
what the [ __ ] I hate you Jesus I can't
make sure he doesn't regenerate is there
another one so please I'll say there's
another one oh oh this is getting tough
they even look that tough
that's what makes them so scary you
underestimate them
the music's going crazy right here
oh I [ __ ] see you me well I think you
said yes okay company if you just
waiting for me there that's really
creepy
I some look down here there's gotta be
something down here
no you telling me there's more of them I
thought I'd got them all I screw this
for this with this with this with this
with this with this there was a green
have I missed the green hat
[Music]
Thank You peace teddy
oh [ __ ] just die you little piece of
[ __ ]
I don't think it's ever gonna work with
this gun
I think sted said I don't think he said
oh my god one more hair and I am dead -
die die die die die die die this is the
colossal waste of my bullets I don't
think this this gun can actually kill it
oh my god I'm actually so freaking it
just shook how many bullets I just sunk
into those things all transit with the
United States is to be made fire
helicopter take extreme care during
takeoff and landing as shocked - the
parcel may potentially litres of
activation we here at the European
branch are excited to hear your thoughts
an evaluation of this newest prototype
and are pleased to offer this specimen
to you for testing no no this I'm not in
danger anymore
can't believe they out she wanted to
ship these guys like they could be
detained okay I got some gunpowder dead
person Oh miss something over here well
it's a red herb so we can at least
combine which is nice
I think is anything else here that I've
missed or is there hello
are you dead it happened a worst-case
scenario the t-virus is somehow leaked
under orders from dr. bard I'm to
manufacture a mask or quantities of the
vaccine
I prepared a culture of the t-virus
antigen now I just need to combine it
with an adjuvant why can't I say that
word I do it
adjoint and you vent to enhance this
effect and I should be able to produce
enough vaccine to save all the surviving
citizens the adjuvant samples are stored
in the incubation lab test subjects are
already wandering the halls but I'd
better find a way to get the samples
while this culture is much maturing if I
don't make it back please complete the
synthesis process try to find a way to
stop this outbreak it's the least we can
do after setting these horrifying events
into motion you not me I don't iron do
that I've been trying to save it from
the start don't want me in with your
stuff Oh what do we have here oh thank
you i actually I need that I am so glad
I really really really really needed
that beautiful yes
hello how do you do my name's Jill oh
[ __ ]
everybody counts
this is back to you anyone ah thank you
I'm guessing is the big red glowing one
cool what did we just do
I don't have enough ammo hohoho
for any of this oh look at them
these are tyrants
this is how mr. axe is made this is the
origins of mr. axe
Jesus
so this is like more like nemesis type
and this is more like mr. X like this is
cool wow they look so derpy
I think I prefer them mr. X ones I think
because they're more humanoid which
makes them more scary because it's the
whole uncanny valley kind of thing you
know oh wait did I miss something I
thought I just saw green however no it's
gonna kick myself
well somehow I don't know how much that
I was so scared but I still managed it
well done me part of me I'm the best
please I I'm out of bullets please die I
think he was already dying I think I
just wasted my bullet
I can't handle this little amaryllis
I think I have a not a gun though
maybe back Oh No
so I'm not even having eesh oh I do have
some shotgun shells too I don't have I
don't have any of that one I've got some
Magnum your [ __ ]
watch it Sonny Boy please give me some
ammo
darzee we're getting oh wait didn't we
pick one up early oh no we made that 100
okay
I'll take it
there we go we got the mom wait how does
she say it at event out of it she said
so elegantly how does she do that
look everyone's a nerd at heart how cute
anyway wait we haven't seen one of those
wobbly heads in a while where are they
Mega Man okay expression of concern
please allow me to send my heartfelt
congratulations to you and your
colleagues and brother Europe for
completing nemesis a truly remarkable
achievement in the field of bioweapons
research and did you see a parasitic
organism into the tyrants brain to gain
external control of it how can I not
marvel it's such a wild idea however
from a medical perspective
I must emphatically state my disapproval
of this shift away from the established
in front of policy by turning to the use
of parasites you're setting a dangerous
precedent viruses can be kept in check I
believe in a fit effective vaccine can
be developed for any virus on earth with
abundant funding in a bounty of sample
scores
can you say the same for parasites
however doctors have tried in vain to
develop a vaccine for malaria parasites
like Plasmodium are far more genetically
complex than the t-virus and think they
would both submit to control it's utter
folly perhaps in your country consumers
are willing to buy automobiles with no
brakes but here in America they know
better then again I recall you have a
degree in economics
so no doubt you've already devised a
brilliant marketing strategy to win over
the naysayers I look forward to your
talk at the Forum in Berlin next month
Berlin cool place in the meantime I
should be exploring medical solutions to
this hubristic problem you voiced on us
sounds more English than an American
well that those fancy words like not to
say that Americans can't sleep fancy
words but you know I I wanted to read
this very posh accent
I mean backtracking all the way back
here
let's go say hi to mr. X again X gon
give it to you deputy
thanks Roz well for your donation and
for believing in me means a lot why do
you believe in me though they got [ __ ]
in their eyes they can't handle it well
[ __ ] this you know what [ __ ] just [ __ ]
it just [ __ ] it I'm going now I got to
defeat them I can't I don't know how to
he's hugging me too close okay
feed us anymore I can't do this and
people oh god oh god oh god oh my god oh
god I put one last shotgun shell
I've got one last acid round oh this is
bad so I've got three Magnum at least I
killed everything in here can I get
under here
oh don't you don't good I thought it's
gonna tell me that wait there's
something behind me yeah explicitly what
suppose of a oh thank you okay here we
go then so we got some explosive rounds
at least
Oh
right I know this gun gunpowder in
another room so we can get ourselves
some more ammo we've got acid rounds
here we've got more explosive rounds
here okay it's not too bad we have a
handgun which has quite a lot of ammo in
it if we need you just take it out and
use it just normal so yeah I'm gonna
take out my shotgun for now and this one
for this one so it's at least got this
gun because it's got some ammo we can
use it up
okay we're back at it again
here we go
as materials detected
oh no I'm only missing step
baby I am missing us that way maybe I
put in the wrong one press okay I'm
doing this from after combine samples of
the two ingredients antigen and G
adjuvant
isn't that what I've got philocan being
very stupid I've forgotten something
Oh combine them what just like in my
hands thought I'd need to use that oh
okay I thought the machine would do that
for me
now I got it
what temperature are we getting so I
guess I'm getting them all into the
center there we go that was easy
who didn't even try
whoo-hoo thanks Roswell for let me know
and for the super jerk to let me know it
doesn't make sense to like combine them
in my hands because isn't that I don't
know dangerous asleep she all doesn't
care
she's bad Oh
[Music]
I know I even have a knife on me
apparently I did
wrong way jail away is it get down here
explosive barrels work every time Oh am
I supposed to buy timing it Oh am I just
spamming it cuz I'm spamming it right
now spamming holding spamming holding
holding holding right right okay
so whenever I see a pulse around the key
I think that means spam because to me
that means to like press and if I see it
multiple times on my Agha you know I'm I
do a lot of things like that let me know
what you see there you go that's take a
long time how convenient
apparently all of you guys could hear me
slamming w I was doing I was like why
isn't it working
ah thank you for all of this yes I'm
gonna get my knife out to get that yeah
that crane so I don't have to waste a
bullet
not a single bullets will be wasted oh
yes some more shotgun shells oh yeah
this is a great room to be in okay now
is everything we're gonna store this one
thanks well we've got explosive we got a
lot of explosive rounds can we combine
these with these no I so I need all of
these guns I mean I'm thinking no but
also I wanna say yes because I know what
I'm like this facility is to be used for
the dissolution and dispersion of test
subjects used in nest 2 experiments the
potent solvents used will ensure that
any biological matter within the bats
living or dead is completely dissolved
and ready for disposal please follow all
safety protocols when using the disk
Center confirmed no employees are in the
chamber always uses a regulated amount
of solvent if it is subject for you I
don't need you not help the disposal
process leave the chamber filled for at
least 12 hours
we got ourselves small flame rounds
but we don't need them so I'm just gonna
film stir right away
don't the vaccine Nikolai don't the city
needs that vaccine
I don't know
but I'm in this business to get it so
let's make a deal you were down there
there for the Nemesis no record it all
and put on a good show
oh why just taking sneaky videos of Joe
it's so creepy
[Music]
Oh God Oh God well that did not go down
well okay I feel like I am massively
underprepared for this I would have
taken more stuff if I knew this was
happening but I did not know but no
excuses no excuses no excuses I'm in
danger or Freddie
[Music]
go go go go gadget go go go go go Jim
exclude him Oh Joe Joe Joe
do him in the face no tip freeze ban oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god how
am I still alive he literally ripped
over my stomach i I do i oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god
Oh God don't think I have any more ammo
let me spot for you
Oh God Oh God I don't have the mind
thing [ __ ] and to look for the mind
thing I know that Carlos thanks you're
really [ __ ] helpful oh right okay
actually no you are where's more stuff
for me to pick up
misoo oh okay if it's this big boy then
I need is very God yeah die Oh God I've
only got two that I don't wanna die okay
uh Jill is no damsel in distress but uh
you know I do think she could have used
tough spot
cool headshot right sweet
that was nice
ah oh my god
we're we're seven three four eight seven
but
was I supposed to I supposed to hit them
I think I'm supposed to do the canister
when he's on there and then when when
Carlos tells you what number to do I
think I'm in danger
Oh God oh this is it this is it this is
the end oh my god
okay okay he's up
Oh
one
oh hell yes are you will away well this
bass boss [ __ ] oh my get guns oh my god
guns goodbye get guns
okay basically I'm just gonna run away
and city sunset oh but until he starts
to jump up the walls again okay great
great great good to go to Kurt Kurt Kurt
Kurt good good good great I'm stuck I'm
broken
what's what's he hiding behind number
one
oh good don't memorize oh my god
too much happening I should have taken
that zombie out before I suppose me
thinking about it oh no oh no please oh
please don't die till I nice I know what
I'm doing now whoa whoa I nice I know
what I'm doing now oh okay let's take
out as many explosive things as we come
because we need this
oh my dear Carlos is like a cheerleader
that's so cute
okay here we go you and me have a
feeling that when I knock him down maybe
I can't count him again cuz it kind of
better takes him for a little bit and I
think it's just to give me a bit of
extra time
okay here yeah - dude - dude dude reload
shoot go [ __ ] up [ __ ] back oh god I like
that it gives me a little audio warning
day hike on us
that's my boy but
whoa did that happen last time I don't
remember that happening last time yeah I
know
six seven eight
Oh Wilson Smith sees that one but
whatever did the job did the job did the
job nice job did the job oh I bet his
breath quite into it
Oh for [ __ ] sake
oh [ __ ]
for
come on
okay good ah [ __ ] Oh thought I killed
you though
shite oh my god I can't see what's
happening I supposed to breathe out now
don't have time to I don't even care
[Music]
yeah I know I know she's behind me she's
behind me right
go get whatever the [ __ ] that is right
oh god oh god oh god oh god I'm scared
okay even turn around too scared
oh god oh god oh god oh god he's coming
he's coming Jerry's coming
I need to find more my health I need to
find wild
okay bye please free low Jill please I
don't want any more right where are they
oh my god oh I don't know what to do Oh
[ __ ] sake
sorry stressful
okay do I take enough out I mean
technically I don't even need that
really can I put this one in here for
now they don't need I'll do this it just
might take a little while so I'm sorry
mm-hm
No
please stay down please stay down don't
get back up number one misses and then
an M&M in this this Oh [ __ ] ugly he
likes that to your liking these apples
why do we say such a brilliant Pharisee
things hit
huh
died nobody likes you get ready in today
see shotguns good day for oh yes oh yes
what are you gonna do
oh come on Jill come on Jill come on
Jill
de carlos is great Karlis believes in us
we can't do this
cor cor cor cor cor where where where
where where out there there there there
there there there there scoop molest
what about that
oh come on come on come on come on come
on come on come on Jill jail stop
Jill Jill
Oh God once all of this I'm gonna girls
I'm [ __ ]
I think it's working
oh it's Olivia okay
[Music]
we're gonna smash in those D oh my god
I'm actually so happy we did it we did
it
sayonara
thanks peace teddy
for the super chat oh look at him you
its nemesis sleep oh my gosh whoever
this is like such a rush I don't know
why of course they do know like that was
so good I think you know when when it's
a tough fight any finally when I kind of
understand all the appeal to Dark Souls
look at this we have nothing in here
it's done give me the vaccine you grease
I like we should make a storm going
now drop the cup
what the hell
is that the remains of nemesis
never seen it it's so incredible
incredible own this would be worth music
oh it is city's about to explore and you
can for the price of life
good luck Jim Oh what about you
we're running out of time
she's so confident I wouldn't be if I
heard just a lotf and hey okay whoa what
is this how is she even holding much she
must have come to steal
[Music]
it means power
okay
wait how am I gonna do this oh hello
hello mmm mmm yum yum yum mmm yummy mm
oh but
get him in there something's oh yeah I
need this
please don't hit me [ __ ] off
I used to hit me every time I do this me
right I need to it's okay I need to
learn the animation no I don't want to
so I guess I need to hit him he's gotta
have weak points like in here wait I'm
missing Oh this loads there's another
book of everything
this thing is Totally Rad tyrants out of
line just give him the finger and
problem solved
oh this is the electromagnetic weapon
Arthur this is the weapon we're about to
use or just use mobility may prove to be
problematic in the field perhaps it flat
its platform could be refined it
requires multiple power sources may be
difficult to secure in practice
okay
this one shooting skip it because I come
above this
he is angry smarty oh [ __ ]
see like an obvious opening to when he's
going to stop okay okay okay it's down
right
oh he did that
I only did me and I think I just freakin
you shot in warm because that's all I
know how to do let me game is my I do
shoot things well I don't
oh yeah yes I will I wasn't saying it's
got none of those things
we want to pick up like her name
yeah Wow I want to play some old-school
horror games
all right let's get this grenade yes
okay
[Music]
let's make it a shortcut to this one
because
how are we gonna get down there oh no no
no no that's risky
yeah I did it twice now I know your game
mechanics whoo
yeah dodged
it girls got moves oh [ __ ] yes maybe
she's not like it
making those annoying noises I'm so
sorry baby I'm stay quiet
oh my god how am i doing for health not
too badly
oh [ __ ]
together one of your chests it keep
hiding for me I need to get over here
you get Leon's last one yeah yeah oh oh
this is risky don't I be in his face
it's not feel nice
okay perfect
right the last verse [ __ ] yeah me too me
too me too Jill me too - I feel you girl
well let's do this
ah like that monstrosity gusting ah bold
thing I love it okay that was super
super super cool that was amazing I
really enjoyed that so good I feel like
all of this blood should be like toxic
but it's not so I guess we'll just walks
the brewery dead nemesis yeah wait
should we go this way
I feel oh I feel I thought we could go
through the fiery hole but no we gotta
go up here
Carlos is gonna be so impressed hell
yeah
[Music]
I don't think there's gonna be much to
pick out cuz I'm pretty sure we're at
the very end of the game
karlof oh come on Carlos
I beat now this all away owner you
couldn't even be Nikolai
[Music]
ah palace was only pretending
I can't okay you do it
anyway
take the shot she won't do it
why'd you do it
there's a price tag
Oh
you're the fool you've frickin shot the
vaccine
and he can't even use on themselves now
what fool
no it wasn't a me at Carlos's head I
wonder if you could have actually shot
Carlos where accident though if that was
like a different ending
the missile
[Music]
[Music]
MD
[Music]
I decided then and there the ashes of
Raccoon City with the umbrellas ashes to
I would end once and for all
yeah Jill
so the storyline none the timeline of
the storyline we got to the police
station before Leon it wasn't evil - but
then we left just as the city was about
to be blown to smithereens so that
basically was alongside wasn't it that's
pretty cool it's pretty cool I know I
know people are disappointed by the
length of this game but I I think it was
pretty good I mean it was no reasonable
to come on and maybe it woods a little
bit pricey for what this is but I enjoy
the fact that it's built upon the
narrative that you played within and
learnt about in the second game perhaps
if you already knew that from
remembering Resident Evil really well
you're a bit like ah because you already
knew that but also in the original
resident evil 3 you had those Nemesis
choices is it a little bit of a shame
they didn't add anything like that into
the game but ultimately I still found it
really enjoyable that last boss ball was
very intense and I really enjoyed it it
was definitely more action than Resident
Evil 2
not as many kind of slower paced scary
moments I'm interested to see what
they're gonna do next was I hear they're
going to do Resident Evil 4 isn't it and
I did actually play that one for about
other than maybe an hour when I was a
kid and I couldn't because it was way
too scary way too hard and I could not I
just could not play that game I'm more
excited for Resident Evil 8 because when
the evil 7 was so good it was so so so
good and it was just it was pure
survival horror with obviously a little
bit of action
but way more survival horror than
Resident Evil 2 all three we make so I'm
really excited to see what they deal
with present evil 8 and I hope they
stick to that old-school horror uh kind
of roots because it reminds him it was
very reminiscent of more of a Silent
Hill type game which I loved Silent Hill
the game is good but it's not a remake
not really yeah I guess I don't remember
Resident Evil through well enough to say
how it stands up against the original
game but I do know that they took those
choices away and that's that's a shame
because they the original had loads of
alternate endings and a lot of
replayability and I don't know this this
game doesn't really have that doesn't so
that's a bit of a shame okay well anyway
whatever they do with the remake is for
I'm probably gonna play it anyway but
I'm Way more excited for wasn't evil eh
and I'm pretty sure that one's gonna
come out before fall anyway
Oh someone picked up the vaccine that
had been shot I got the C ranked me it's
been it's been a good time
I will live stream again next week make
sure to follow me on Twitter or you can
i'll give you an invite to the discord
group i hope you all have a good night
and I'll see soon again
okay I'm going bye